do you know what uh
elon thinks about this idea of rapid
testing for everybody so i i understood
i need to look at that whole twitter
thread
so i understand his perhaps criticism of
uh he had like a conspiratorial tone
from my vague look at it of like
what's going on here with these tests uh
but
what does he actually think about this
very practical to me engineering
solution of just deploying rapid tests
to everybody
it seems like that's a way to open up
the economy in april
well to be honest i've been trying to
get in touch with him again i think
take somebody like elon musk with the
engineering prowess within his ranks you
know to
easily easily build these at the tens of
millions a day
he could build the machines from scratch
you know a lot of the companies they buy
the machines from
south korea or taiwan i believe
we don't have to like we can build these
machines they're simple to build
get put somebody like elon musk on it
you know take some of his best engineers
and say look
the us needs a solution in two weeks
build these machines you know figure it
out he'll do it he could do it this is a
guy who
who is literally he has started multiple
entirely new industries
he has the capital to do it without the
us government if he wanted to
and you know what it would the return on
investment
and for him would be huge but frankly
the return on investment in the
country would be hundreds of billions of
dollars
because it means we could get society
open so i know that he
his first experience with these rapid
tests was confusing
which is um how i ended up having this
twitter kind of conversation with him
very briefly
but i think that if if he understood
sort of a little bit more and i think he
does i really
really love to talk to him about it
because i think he could totally change
the course of this pandemic in the
united states
single-handedly you know he loves grand
things yeah i think out of all the
solutions i've seen this is
uh this is the obvious like engineering
solution
to uh at least a pandemic of this scale
i i love that you say the engineering
solution so this is something i've been
really trying to
i'm an engineer you know my previous
history was
all engineering and that's really how i
think um i then went into medicine and
phd world but
um but but i i think that the world like
one of the major catastrophes or one of
the major
problems is that we have physicians
making the decisions about public health
and a pandemic when really we need
engineers
this is an engineering problem and so
what i've been trying to do i actually
really want to you know start a whole
new new field called public health
engineering
you know and so i've been i'm loving it
eventually i want to try to bring it to
mit and get mit to want to start a new
department or something
um that's it's a doubly awesome idea
that this is really okay i love this i
love
every aspect i love everything you're
talking about
you